him  all right look at him jeff green  gets it into durant here is durant  moving on tucker  he turns  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  what an incredible shot by  kevin durant  gathers his feet the question is was his  toe on the line and it looks like from  that angle  it was on the line still a beautiful  shot by duran  off balance fading away tucker in his  face  and able to concentrate and step up  and knock down that shot but from that  angle marv it looked like  definitely toe on the line and depending  upon what happens  is what they called in this last second  we might be in for overtime  yeah i i don't think it's any question  you look at that replay  which means it's tied at 109. we haven't  gotten the official word yet